so this is a
study sorry this is from 2020 uh and
it's oh look it's fact check too maria
did us a favor and fact checked this for
us so it's got to be accurate right
a new study indicates men and women
between the age of 18 and 24 are having
less sex less often uh delayed adulthood
maybe maybe one factor they also go down
and blame covid for this as well too for
some reason but i'll deal with that too
um amount of material internet
face-to-face now they expand on a little
bit more here people are having less sex
and the decline is being seen among
younger adults particularly men
guys this is not new we've seen
i've probably seen at least three
articles in the last few years on this
um they all conclude the same thing
young men are not getting what they're
wanting from women
uh why they're here on the planet to
scatter seed right that's that's why
we're here we're just a bunch of
advanced monkeys that figured out how to
make roads and drive cars and broadcast
stuff on youtube platforms and stuff
like that
uh but dudes are not getting what
they're wanting so
um they go on to blame things like the
internet dating apps morality fear of
pregnancy sure because that's never been
around right easy access to porn that's
always been around i mean even when i
was a kid before the internet there was
always magazines lying around somewhere
in someone's house
um
about one in three million men ages 18
to 24 reported no sexual activity in the
past year the links there if you guys
want to read the study now there was
something here
where they were talking about um
men as far as here it is
unmarried okay this is the point here
that i wanted to hit on
unmarried
setting aside the unmarried part because
that's not really that significant
low-income
and unemployed or part-time employed men
were more likely to have no sex within
the past year than those who were
married had high income or had jobs
now
how many times have i hit on the
significance look money status game
being captivating and interesting all
that stuff
if
you're not working or you're not
bringing in an income that's significant
enough to
you know to compete with the guys in
your demographic
and i mean it's it's pretty
straightforward to do you can you can
download any dating app and then you can
switch over so that you're behaving on
the app as if you're a woman and then
see what guys in your region
do like a 20 kilometer or 20 mile
radius
see what guys look like compared to you
and how do you look like compared to the
competition how do you stack up
basically is what i'm saying right and
if women have to choose
higher income
more gainfully employed
guys that are doing the work in their
life what do they say here uh had higher
income or had jobs pretty
pretty like low barrier to entry if you
know for being honest right like to make
more money is not that hard there's just
some work that you have to do to level
up your skills and advance them you know
i've said this so many times like the
crowd out there that's like yeah rich
you just think it's so easy to make a
million dollars money just floating out
there and you can just grab it and yeah
you can you can all you have to do is
have some significant skills like if you
want fu money you have to have fu skills
and the problem is is most guys don't
they don't do the work on themselves and
i'll be honest with you like
a lot of dudes will be like yeah you're
right
but
a lot of this stems from your childhood
a lot of the stems from your upper ring
i know something like 43 percent of guys
are now raised in single-parent
households moms can play the fine role
of being a mother but they suck at
playing the role of a father and
instilling masculine virtues and then
there's the percentage of men there in
households that just do a piss-poor job
of being fathers maybe they're a piece
of furniture and they take little
interest in their children could be any
number of things but there's not a lot
of strong male leaders that instill
these values now if you're 18 19 20 and
you're just coming out of your parents
home
okay i can you know i'll nod my head
with you and be like that sucks
but
if you're in your 20s or your 30s you
don't have any excuses there's an
abundance of free information out there
that can show you how to level up and
what work is required to get those
results out of your life that you're
looking for but if you're just gonna
like hang on to the victim mindset and
you know look at others doing the work
and be jealous or be envious of them i
mean that's just a path to loserdom and
you can go down that path and there's a
lot of people that hang out there and
lose to them but you're not going to get
what you're looking for down there
you're never going to find it down there
now this article goes on to start
blaming things like delayed adulthood
may be a factor covid may be a factor
digital media distractions may be a
factor
you know blah blah blah covet isn't
helping there's a lot of guys that i
know that have just like they just
racked up ridiculous notch cancer in
this coba 19 thing because there was no
bars there was no first dates to go to
there was no drinks to have it was just
like come over you know on the first
date
um it's
like a lot of these are just coping you
know for being honest with you um i'm
going to say
you know like stuff like this where
we're talking about
these specific categories of dudes let
me grab that um let me pull this out
here let me grab that comment this dude
left here on my
thing
where are we going
if you guys follow me on instagram
you're gonna recognize that i posted it
the other day
um let me go bigger here
no that's not bigger where's bigger
there's bigger
so
i posted this day you know just as a
spoof i just said something like so all
i heard you got to do is stand in front
of some big chicken wings and you can uh
sell and only fans and your bathwater
and farts in a bottle but uh most guys
got the joke but this but this younger
fellow over here
uh liam you said you've put out some
great content on youtube man but please
start to acknowledge the incel
epidemic a bit more
so if you don't know what that is
there's guys out there that want to be
intimate with women but they're not
having any success with it
most guys nowadays can't even get a text
back never mind spin plates being alpha
hitting the gym and getting on your
purpose just isn't enough for many guys
to even get their looks matched nowadays
sounds like a little bit of
self-deprecation and a sulk let's uh
show these
things so i basically said hey man
uh watch less content that supports a
victim mindset and do work if you want
the results he says i've read your book
i've read rollo's books i've consumed
nearly all of your content up to about
three months ago so we stopped consuming
it
young women are dating more on physical
attraction than ever before not true
they've always done that
uh
the rp does not go far enough into the
importance of looks maxing i think it
covers it pretty significantly we've got
looks money game frame
captivation your social standing you
know your influence out there
uh i also don't have a victim mindset as
still do the work so he's claiming he
does the work so again hopefully my
friend you're gonna call in today and
we'll be able to chop it up and see if
we can get the bottom of this
it's not always the guy's fault if he
has little success in today's era now
there's this there's this term here
genetic determinism
and i thought to myself that's an
interesting phrase that sounds like
something the doomers would use
so you go to youtube and you type in
genetic determinism and of course
there's videos out there from the dark
loser corner of the youtubes basically
saying look because of these factors
you're screwed and then they'll sell you
some
you know looks maxing assessment saying
that your jawline is broken or something
like that
there's also videos out there by the way
that uh
take a very hard scientific look at
genetic determinism from like published
people that know what they're talking
about and there's a lot of debate on the
subject
and really all of it all that that boils
down to all they're really saying is
well your genetics are going to
determine your success or your outcomes
in life and that's not true and i can
prove that and i will prove it again in
this to kind of bring you guys a little
bit of glimmer of light with this
because doom and gloom kind of you know
bugs me anyway i invite the guy to call
in the show
a few other people chime in here hit the
gym muscles to do
he says he's going to try to come in
uh let's can i click this link it's
probably a public profile
it doesn't look like a bad looking dude
and well
here's one of your problems my friend
you're you're on social media but you
don't have any posts
right
that's you know that's one of the
realities of today's world when it comes
to dealing with um
women
because they like guys with social
influence what have i said captivation
be interesting don't be boring right
you're not even leading a life that is
worth publishing on the internet
that's one of the areas that you can
start with so even though you say that
you've read the book and you've watched
the material and all that sort of thing
by your actions and when there's a
conflict between words and actions what
do we do we believe the actions i've
been telling you this guy i've been
telling this for a long time just don't
deal with women too many of you focus on
getting girls
and there's more out there than just
that
pay attention to what people are doing
in all areas of life
work business transactions
conversations like this i look at all of
it man i look at all of it
you